bonjour comment vous appelez qu'on sache
oui bonjour je m'appelle michel brieu
l'âge vient de limoger vous présenter
une nouvelle application qui s'appelle
limouzy victor
li musique alors ça ça parle de quoi
limogé moi j'ai vu tourner donc je sais
un peu mais pour nos amis sur youtube
alors bannie musique en fête
bon déjà il faut savoir que la musique
polyphonique vient du limousin au xième
siècle avec la vie de saint martial
il ya mille ans d'histoire de la musique
en fête qui ont démarré
si on démarre en limousin c'est le début
de la pop et du rock quoi voilà c'est ça
ouais en limousin s'est laissée là où
les premiers troubadours ont commencé à
chanter en langage vernaculaire séance
que le latin et donc ils ont inventé la
pop on imagine mal goldman ou elvis
presley chanter tes deum année nous y
avait cette spéciale est comme ça c'est
bizarre quand même
voilà donc bien cette application
pourquoi c'est c'est une web application
c'est en fait ça c'est une page web
on va retrouver sur ce collègue sur
votre site voilà on se connecte sur le
site correspond à créer amazon va la
sncf d'accord en fait on va aller ouvrir
la page applications on va jouer
directement sur le
sur la page web donc accessible quel que
soit le support mac pc tablettes
portables qwerty/azerty il ya aucun
problème
c'est une page web du monde est connecté
au web en aient accès à la musique
d'accord alors qu'à qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire très concrètement avec les
musiques c'est quoi l'intérêt qu'elle
est là qu est ce qu est ce qu on peut en
faire
c'est pour les musiciens c'est alors
c'est pour tout le monde c'est un
instrument de musique voilà ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre c'est que ça
d'instruments de musique d'accord qui
devrait vendus dans des magasins de
musique mais comme il est totalement
dématérialisée en fait il a plus sa
plombé s'apparenter aux jeux vidéo on va
dire mais on va pouvoir oublier sa
guitare et son piano et on va pouvoir
jouer de manière polyphonique sur sa
tablette directement donc là vous avez
des touches directement sans clavier
voilà donc alors ses neuf touches là ici
représentent ces sept touches en couleur
représente 9 touches les touches
utilisées par la majorité des chansons
et chaque fois qu'on est passé de ses
touches donc bien sûr ça joue là mais ça
repart à mettre les autres touches par
exemple ici fusion d'accord alors on va
se passer grâce à ces neuf touches du
solfège on va utiliser en fait le
principe des tablatures que connaissent
bien les guitaristes way et chaque fois
qu'on va appuyer sur une de ces neuf
touches savard paramétrer les autres
touchent donc là on va se passer le
solfège et avec un solo je vais faire un
accord de 3 son guitariste doit prendre
ces accords là ils sont tous fait un
simple c'est un peu la musique pour les
nuls quoi exactement
c'est hyper facilitant donc je change
mon avantage
j'ai un nouvel accord qui fait que je
peux jouer très rapidement la majorité
du répertoire le beau jeu sa couronne
alors
bon sang
c'est vrai que lille aubin
1 on peut faire pratiquement tous les
répertoires de bach à goldman en passant
par les beatles pour avoir se passer
complètement du solfège il suffit
d'aller sur internet chercher la grille
d'accords c'est à dire le texte des
paroles avec la ligue d'accord on va
venir dans le petit utilitaire qui
fournit dans l'interface de réglage de
limousis qu on met à 0 il suffit de
cocher des accords de la chanson est
automatiquement le logiciel va nous
donner le code couleur donc il suffit de
remplacer les accords de la chanson
qu'on trouve sur internet par un code
couleur tout simplement et partant de là
on va pouvoir faire pratiquement tout le
répertoire et surtout tout ce qui est
pop et tout ce qui est variété d'accord
voilà une petite démo alors peu connu
par exemple quelque chose de le roi
dagobert en connaît tous mais tous les
actuels quoi on va faire un petit
coleman
on va faire un petit col malheur vouvry
la chasa
donc ma main droite va pas bouger et
j'ai juste à enchaîner les accords de la
chanson pour d'accord pour faire demain
il
à
de la ligue
gaymard
ben
et puisque tu es mon tour
il est con ce champ
et c'est après que faire une chose très
simple ouah
le
je suis
à
paris
m
oh
voilà donc on peut pas jouer fout en
fait c'est ça mais ça reste quand même
du live voilà ces actions on s'amuse à
faire un
ans
l'irak à l'époque à calais marck amaya à
l'époque à bas les masques
non
m
alors
non
il faut pas louper les touches le bon
c'est très facile de faire répertoire
c'est une solution qui s'adresse aux
musiciens à ce qu'ils ne sont pas
forcément qu'ils veulent l'être à ceux
qui veulent faire du live on peut faire
du live avec est ce qu'on peut faire
encore avec pascal le sait qu'il faut
forcément une connexion internet si vous
n'avez pas de connexion internet ça
marche pas voilà alors cessé c'est ça
peut être une des flammes les époux du
produit mais c'est aussi une de ses
forces c'est à dire que tous les
supports sont admissibles
d'accord contrairement avec des choses
qui vont se développer que pour ios ou
android est le g1 android voilà donc là
par exemple là c'est bon le navigateur
c'est la seule android ici fut sur
safari sur mon ordinateur en général je
suis sûr prom et ya aucun souci donc
c'est destiné à tout le monde c'est à
dire que la personne qui a un jour
essaient de faire la guitare qui
s'achetait une guitare et puis qui au
bout de quinze jours avait mal aux
doigts mal au poignet puis donc cette
personne là elle va apprécier les
musiques toutes les personnes qui
chantent qui sont pas instrumentistes
tous les instrumentistes monophonique
c'est les gens qui font la clarinette du
violon ils vont pouvoir apprendre leur
entourage à faire quelques petits
accompagnement et ils vont pouvoir jouer
partout on peut faire un peut très bien
faire un boeuf avec ça et aucun problème
ça va être surtout destiné alors il ya
des gens qui auraient jamais l'idée de
s'acheter un son de musiques tous les
gens qui présentent un handicap
psychomoteur
ouais pas cela on a vu qu'on n'a pas
besoin de solfège donc en termes de
ressources mentales on a besoin de très
peu de choses des gens qui ont des
ressources physiques très diminués avec
deux doigts
on peut faire aussi beaucoup de choses
on peut vraiment se faire plaisir là où
il attaquerait jamais un piano une
guitare est la cible principale on va
dire qu'on prête à aujourd'hui c'est
beaucoup les enseignants du primaire
voilà parce qu'ils soient obligés
d'animer des classes musicales et en
fait ils ont comme outil ils prennent la
note sur un petit bout de xylophone
ils font chanter leurs élèves sur une
bande voilà ils peuvent pas démarrer
quand ils veulent en fait assez
compliqué où il chante a cappella et on
sait que pour prendre la note de départ
c'est compliqué et quand on chante a
cappella lanotte a tendance à baisser on
voit toujours ça
quand on chante joie les anniversaires
ou des choses comme ça chacun dans son
coin et puis on se retrouve à l'arrivée
ou pas ça peut éviter la flûte à l'école
ça pourrait oui bien sûr bien sûr bien
sûr à c'est pourquoi je crois qu'il sait
des souffrances que je crois qu'ils ont
des jeunes qui peuvent en donner
en fait ils ont pas trop d'autres
solutions
en terme de pratique vraiment
instrumental d'accord voilà et après
pour les musiciens ont effectivement un
pianiste guitariste y aura pas forcément
besoin de ça par contre ça va permettre
de comprendre comment fonctionne la
musique parce qu'en fait le principe de
2,10 nozick c'est le principe de
l'harmonie le classique donc c'est ce
qui a servi à composer depuis back
jusque toute la musique savante jusqu'au
début du 20e siècle
d'accord on arrivait dans le
dodécaphonisme et des choses compliquées
par contre ce principe a été repris
ensuite par les nord américains les
esclaves qui ont créé le blues et le
rock d'accord là et donc toute la pop
aujourd'hui voilà tous deux arrivent
tout ou dérives de ce principe d'accord
donc on peut faire du goldman des
beatles celui dédié réac pratiquement
tout ce qu'on verra si une solution qui
coûte combien
parce que si on va au rex à votre site
je pense qu'il faut un compte alors il
ya deux solutions qui sont totalement
gratuites sens en compte sans abonnement
d'accord il ya un jeu sur le type du sim
ont certes pu les touches sont noirs y
en a une qui s'ouvre on refait et puis
petit à petit en jouant le jeu on va
jouer la musique
d'ailleurs on va apprendre à jouer la
musique les différents types
d'accompagnement la valse le captant
voilà on a une petite partition il ya
une partie gratuite complètement avec
ces quatre accords là qu'ils sont ce
qu'on appelle la nature du sol la
mineure fin kif qui permettent de faire
des milliers des milliers de chansons et
ensuite le premium qui est cette version
là et gratuite sous conditions
d'abonnement dix minutes par jour voilà
donc au bout de dix minutes ça bascule
sur le site youtube de la musique où il
ya des tutoriels des démos et des
partitions d'accord voilà
et puis après on peut on arrive à leur
connecter sans trop de problèmes et puis
après les personnes qui veulent
l'utiliser sans être embêté il ya un
abonnement donc voilà il faut aussi
s'inscrire est un formulaire comme pour
la pour la version gratuite du premium
et puis là on paye donc ses 3 euros 4,3
euros 80 2 euros 99 pardon pour un mois
jusqu'à 14 99 pour un an
donc ça ferait un euro 25 par mois ou
chercheurs donc ça reste très
raisonnable
ok voilà et donc voilà sur www.la
musique pop avec le lien dans la
description
voilà on a tout les toutes les
informations le dossier de presse aussi
et donc sur le site des musiques
youtube on a une trentaine de vidéos et
je vais en rajouter au fur et à mesure
ok voilà plus que facebook plus de
twitter lee musique plus les yukes ou en
chine
bonjour le chinois et le widget en chine
parce que comme facebook va pas là-bas
et du coup vous serez présent vous me
disiez au csa vegas tout à fait alors
j'ai déjà deux médailles d'argent
concours lépine avec les musiques bardot
et puis donc j'étais sélectionné hirsch
était aux jeunes vert es donc c'était le
petit salon parisien de préparation au
csa de las vegas et donc je suis
sélectionné à l'oreca parc
donc c'est vraiment une sélection sur
les start up innovantes donc à las vegas
en janvier prochain
est ce qu'on peut dire que limoges
valvegas limoges va à las vegas
raccourci facile mais bien sûr le but de
lee musique c'est de rappeler un peu les
racines des racines musicales et parce
qu'en fait on 6ème siècle c'était une
époque où les artistes ne signez pas
leurs oeuvres qu'ils soient artistes
musiciens peintres ou qu'ils soient
artistes artisans parce qu'il ya toute
une vie à tout un artisanat de deux d'or
de cuivre des mailles de l'époque
et ce qui fait qu'en fait c'est un peu
tombé dans l'oubli c'est ses origines
polyphonique de la musique d'accord vu
que les hommes n'étaient pas signés ok
super solution merci de me l'avoir bc -
merci merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
je vous invite à aller voir le site de
limousis cas
les et l'essayer le tester vous allez
voir c'est super ludique très sympa et
puis quand on y réfléchit et qu'on
compte pratique on s'en rend compte
qu'il n'ya pas d'application soit pour
des grands pour les petits il ya plein
de choses à faire
regardez ça aller l'essayer mais témoin
aux commentaires du post que vous en
pensez et puis merci puis à très bientôt
pour de la nouvelle technologie
salut merci
longtemps qu'il aurait mieux
et qui doit
aura pas fait d'émules aux idéologies
des coûts type de fonds
les armes
partez en famille tout et bellamy et
mène aussi
on est assassin
vidéo
emilie millions
on peut se tromper voilà c'est un peu
non sais c'est que je connais par coeur
je crois je suis pas itunes
je suis pas utile je connais pas par
coeur toutes les chansons